I want you to think of how you approach
the idea of the quality of your
healthcare in this country in the United
States for those of you who are watching
this from the United States typically
you would ask around to make sure that
you had a good doctor you would try to
get a referral from your existing
primary care providers so called PCP or
you would ask your friends who had been
in similar situations and sort of
triangulate and figure out who the
doctors were but he would also have the
support of a variety of institutional
mechanisms that would ensure that the
quality of the doctor that you were
seeing was sufficiently high supposed to
reassure you that your care was me put
in a good persons hands not just a
competent professional but also a good
ethical person there are lists published
monthly annually semi-annually in the
United States and the best doctors and
this and that specialty there are of
course institutions that are ranked and
rated all the time by different
Commission's of the US government there
are magazines that specialize in ranking
doctors and medical care facilities on a
variety of dimensions there is a
veritable cornucopia of different
ratings and you might have the opposite
problem that you'd have in other parts
of the world that here there is too much
data to base your decision on but you
would not be short of being able to get
the right information that you need to
make a good choice of a doctor that
information is woefully missing in most
parts of the world you would of course
still essentially ask your friends and
family to figure out who the doctors
were but beyond that you would have much
less assurance that the doctor that
you're seeing is of except to be high
quality now of course if you were in the
privileged classes you would find a way
around this but for the vast majority of
people in South Asia in developing
countries it is very hard to access a
doctor let alone worry about the
possibility that that the doctor is not
credentialed is not ethical is not
sufficiently trained has not had
continuing education these are all
nicely is that don't even cross the
minds of anybody if there is a doctor
with a red cross sign outside that seems
to work just fine this is this
absence of information is what I refer
to as an institutional void that's a
mouthful but void simply refers to the
idea that something is missing here are
the piece of information that's missing
is reliable information about the doctor
how do I find a good primary care
provider how do I find a good
gastroenterologist how do I find a good
ophthalmologists how do I find a good
oncologist depending on what my need is
it is fiendishly difficult in a sense
when you peel back the the complexities
and the ethical dimensions and the human
dimensions of health care there is a
basic elemental need here which is to
bring together people who have something
to exchange economists would call this
buyers and sellers coming together here
the buyer is the patient he I'm gonna
use he since I'm thinking of myself he's
a buyer of medical services and the
doctor is the seller of medical services
I realize calling them buyers and
sellers isn't the most natural way but
bear with me for a second to get the
buyer and seller to come together we
basically need a little bit of
information that's credible so that the
buyer can find the seller and vice versa
that information is actually so taken
for granted in different parts of the
world and so completely difficult to
engineer in an institutionalized
capacity when you stop to think what it
takes to make sure that that information
is reliable easily accessible credible
reproducible regenerate able to coin a
word for a second you realize that
there's a lot of complexity to it and
when that information is not there then
you have the most basic breakdown a
doctor can't find his patient and a
patient can't find his doctor and
medical care does not get delivered and
that's a problem